[Musique]
l'automobile est souvent l'objet de
découverte insolite un artisan parisien
vient de construire une renault 5 à 6
roues dont quatre sont motrices cette
solution est souvent utilisée sur les
véhicules tout terrain mais quel est
l'intérêt d'une telle réalisation sur
une petite voiture de tourisme
l'enquète de bernard giraud après la
tyrrell voici la r5 à six roues
pourquoi sir ou étude de style gadget ou
révolution technique construite par un
artisan ce modèle unique présente
certains avantages meilleure tenue de
route distance de freinage réduite de 33
% poids de charge accrue de 750 kg moi
j'ai constaté qu'avec une rolls on
traitait de [ __ ] de riches etc
tandis qu'avec celle là on fait des
signes d'amitié et de gentillesse et et
pour draguer finalement si rousset c'est
bien et oui l'important c'est d'y croire
à chacun ses charmes et ses arguments
qu'attendez-vous de cette voiture eh ben
on en fabrique et avec renault puisque
c'est le constructeur de cette voiture
et c'est un modèle que j'ai créé donc
j'ai envie que tout le monde puisse la
voir et à des prix intéressants
on a déjà rencontré plusieurs idées
insolites en matière de construction
d'une ville mais très peu sont
concrétisées et standardisée souvent
parce que les gens s'en occupe pas bon
moi j'ai envie de m'en occuper j'ai
envie d'y arriver
moi j'ai déjà pas mal de gens dans la
construction automobile qui approuve
cette voiture et qui si vous voulez med
parce que le projet aboutisse simplement
pour la draguer la frime non non non
pour des questions utilisation courante
pour éviter d'avoir des voitures qui
consomment de trop toutes les pièces
proviennent des r5 de série
l'installation d'un deuxième messieurs
et les aménagements nécessaires
reviennent à environ 20 mille francs
la voiture est allongée de 71 cm elle
peut être conçu également avec six roues
motrices pour le tout terrain
[Musique]